[Applauso]
siamo di nuovo in prigione Guardate
siamo in una prigione gigante questa
volta cioè noi siamo piccolissimi ma
siamo in una prigione gigante Qua c'è un
altro
carcerato vedete
Sì ho visto qualcosa sotto c'è un piatto
con delle patatine
credo che arriveremo anche lì al cibo
giganti
emozionato Ma lascia anche la guardia
gigante quindi questa è un'escape Room
un po' speciale però è gigante Sì ci
hanno rimpiccioliti Non vedo l'ora di
vedere come sarà Ma voi ovviamente
Mettetevi comodi prendete i Baustelle
mi piace qua sotto e iniziamo subito
questa nuovissima idea Ok oh oh oh
entrambi Ok Wow super interessante
vedere tutte le cose giganti Qua c'è
quest'altro carcerato perché è un
termometro bisogna andare sul termometro
Credo di sì no non mi dirmi chi mangia
No mi dispiace Vitale bacio ha mangiato
Io non voglio uscire da quella parte lì
no perché questi Escape Room in realtà è
un po' diversa quindi è un po'
particolare ci sono tutte le cose
giganti sono
il capitano
tutti e guarda da quella parte lì Rosa
Sembra che abbia tipo una marmitta
dietro Vabbè siamo nel gabinetto vai che
schifo
Stai attento a non cadere nell'acqua del
gabinetto perché l'acqua sia molto
pulita Non lo so sono qui Guardami Oh mi
vedi Ciao ciao ciao
aspetta aspetta
Uh pulisci la carta igienica gigante e
aspetta sto salendo sopra il gabinetto
perché ogni tanto dove sei eccoti Eccoti
vedi Ciao Ciao Ciao Andiamo avanti
Eccomi qua
e ora oh Dobbiamo andare nell'altro
gabinetto cosa ci fa questo righello qua
sopra eh eh fanno apposta per noi per
passare No dobbiamo entrare nell'acqua
del gabinetto
stiamo portando nell'acqua del rubinetto
per fortuna che è abbastanza pulita Eh
penso però sì Vediamo se troviamo
qualcosa di strano
Forse stiamo scendendo giù nelle fogne
Non lo so ma come facciamo a trattenere
il respiro per così tanto tempo il rosso
è evitare è morto sono riuscito
siamo usciti ma ora rientriamo in acqua
ma è proprio strano cosa sta succedendo
È stranissima
amore freddo bisogna risalire
dappertutto
Ok ok
ho capito ehm Ma che schifo dobbiamo
salire su un verme Ma in che senso per
me apro una bella notizia Questa era il
lavandino non il gabinetto
Eh Sicuramente non era molto pulito qua
quindi c'era pure un verde uh uh uh
il cibo gigante credo che non puoi
passare di là dobbiamo passare qua
le sbarre della prigione Ok credo che
sarà più facile scappare da questo
prigione Perché noi siamo piccolini
possiamo infilarci in mezzo alle sbarre
scappare forse io non vedo l'ora di
andare a mangiare forse non arriviamo lì
nella Mascolo Arriviamo arriviamo
No no no Ah ah ah sei mancato tanto così
da arrivare sulla mela Quindi cosa
vorresti mangiare da quel vassoio
Allora c'è quello Spring roll
l'involtino primavera che è molto
piccante
Ok
la salsa maionese e il ketchup da
mettere sulle patatine ma c'è anche la
senape e stiamo andando da un'altra
parte ho paura che non prenderemo io con
il cibo Mi dispiace per te Ciao Ma tu
sei avanti Sì sto per entrare aiuto
Complimenti
vediamo Eccomi andiamo Uh Dove siamo
adesso non lo so ma io son caduto
dall'altra parte
tunnel non riesco a capire che parte del
prigione Questa è una cucina Forse eh
Ehi Ma sembra più tipo un deposito con
tutte le cose buttate lì proviamo a
buttarsi in uno di questi tunnel uh uh e
dove sei Mi sono sfracellato hai preso
il tunnel giusto tu sì
Ehi ma quale sarà non riesco a trovarlo
era il primo a destra abitavo sicuro ma
non c'è più cibo Mi dispiace tutti non
funzionano E allora sei sfigato no
Eccomi ce l'ho fatta Ok ma che cosa sono
questi sono dei telefoni giganti Mi
dispiace per te ma no Io volevo il cibo
lo potete dire forse ci arriveremo Dopo
non lo so scriveteci nei commenti Quali
sono le vostre Escape Room preferite
Quindi ad esempio le mie preferite sono
quelle a scuola e
persone invece scriveteci le vostre
preferite nei commenti le mie preferite
Vediamo se indovinate quali sono quelle
con il cibo vero Sì è difficile da
indovinare
quando ci sono quelle con il cibo perché
mi distraggo
Guarda noi siamo arrivati da là dove c'è
quel prigioniero lì abbiamo già fatto un
sacco di strada vero
in vantaggio ciao ciao Ehi guarda c'è il
cibo qua sotto guarda guarda guarda
guarda guarda
Oh ci sono anche Ah ah ah ah vado avanti
ciao ciao
ciao a tutti che cosa ci aspetta nella
prossimo round che parte ci sarà della
prigione andremo veramente
Cosa c'è qui cioè vedo già qualcosa
sapone Ah allora di nuovo nelle docce eh
peperoncino Mi dispiace c'è un sacco di
sapone eh eh Come faccio a sfracellarlo
Ma pure io mi sono spregelato A volte
c'è qualcosa che non quadra
non ho toccato l'acqua perché mi sono
sfracellata Forse perché perché se vuoi
scivolati sul sapone È normale
superato l'uscita io sono ancora
indietro
Uh da qua possiamo vedere Vitale che va
verso il sapone Eccolo qua lo vedete
l'ultimo ce l'ho fatta
ok eh eh Vedi che siamo in cucina c'è un
coltello già qui eh forse siamo vicini
alla cucina vediamo
laser i miei nemici numero uno in cucina
non capisco
siamo arrivati in cucina vi immaginate
se poi non c'è la cucina in questo
scherzo certo
ti sei fatto prendere dai laser
sicuramente ciao ciao
dobbiamo andare qua oh oh oh oh
Sì sì stiamo avvicinando al cibo forse
ma una matita che ci fa questa matita
gigante in cucina meglio che eviti le
parti nere dove sei Sei salito no no no
no
mi sto ancora sfracellando non ci credo
meglio così così io posso vincere Sì sì
adesso vediamo Chi prenderà il badge per
primo ma io sto scivolando da righello
anch'io Ciao
i tavoli i tavoli se ci sono i tavoli
vuol dire che stiamo per mangiare
scordatelo
proprio che non ci sia nessun cibo Qua
invece penso di sì allora dice che
dobbiamo salire su questa scala Oh fammi
salire Che bello essere piccolini e
saltare delle cose giganti
lì ci sono le sbarre c'è una telecamera
c'è la guardia dobbiamo andare dove c'è
la guardia e riuscire a passare senza
che la guardi ci vedo vicino Eh insomma
non vicinissimo Però forse riusciremo a
trovare il modo di dire No devi fare in
giro dovevi fare un giro d'acqua Eh sì
oh oh oh è vero
Adesso si è superato e ci sono ci sono
Sono proprio qui dietro di te Uhm
Non so come mai sfracellando poche volte
strano
nessuno maledizione Quindi tu
Poverino ma ti sei proprio spiaccicato
Ehi aspetta un momento dove bisogna
andare quindi non mi fa passare Ah c'è
qualcosa che sta facendo un po' di non
lo so Ci sono invisibili
Uh forse riusciamo a scappare dalla
finestra però guarda proviamo bisogna
saltellare sempre siamo usciti dalla
finestra adesso
[Musica]
abbiamo già preso il pezzo in avanti tu
Ehi no questa Escape Room Allora ho
un'idea così
Escape Room proviamo qua siamo finiti
nella gelateria cervello
prima non è riuscito a prendere nessun
cibo quindi ora sarà molto molto felice
posso il proprietario della gelateria
impazzito prova a scappare Ok va bene
aiutato mi mangio un po' di gelato qui
Ciao ciao ciao
Ah pure tu sfracellata Anch'io mi sono
fatta distrarre dal gelato Allora
vediamo qual è il vostro gusto di gelato
Così non lo stavo chiedendo a te la
stavo chiedendo a loro
scrivete il vostro gusto di gelato
preferito nei commenti il tuo cioccolato
lo sappiamo molto bene
usare ama il cioccolato la porta sembra
essere chiusa cerca di trovare una
chiave per aprire la porta Ok Cerchiamo
la chiave Ma sei riuscita a passare sì
sì sì
dobbiamo trovare la chiave però okay
era facilissimo era proprio qua davanti
questa cosa deve essere più facile come
Escape Room forse forse anche Attento a
cosa abitavano
Invece il mio gusto preferito di gelato
stava volando all'improvviso il mio
gusto preferito è di gelato è pistacchio
e infatti qua c'è il pistacchio vedi il
pistacchio e fragola e quello che cos'è
quello
che dice assicurati di prendere il
bottone giù per aprire la porta ma ci
stanno tirando i gelati in faccia vero
evitare che il lancino un gelato Ah ah
ah apre la bocca Ah Ah Ah Ah Ah abbiamo
premuto il pulsante e ora Adesso dove
dobbiamo andare forse qua sopra Qua c'è
una palla
non cadere ma va ci proviamo Grazie
andiamo proprio io
sono scivolato sul cioccolato No io sono
il pistacchio Ehi sono i nostri gusti
preferiti come facevano a saperlo questi
del gioco riproviamo eh
doppio salto ci vuole il doppio salto OK
riproviamo 1 2 1 2
No dai neanche toccato C'è qualcosa di
strano c'è una maledizione del gelataio
come hai scritto Allora guarda secondo
me Ah ma bisogna saltare qui guarda
tela Ma che tondi non capisco
forse ci hanno detto Come fare Ci
vediamo stasera certo
facili ci sono immaginiamo comunque in
continuazione
sempre lì sul gelato Tra l'altro Ah ah
ah ce la faranno questa volta i nostri
errori allora guardate ce la fai
[Risate]
ci provo Vediamo vediamo vediamo
più avanti più avanti più avanti dove
[Musica]
vai vai vai a superare questo sei ok 25
giorni dopo allora ragazzi Vitale si è
sfasciato altri 10 milioni di volte
proprio gelato al cioccolato preferito
ma finalmente ci siamo Eh vabbè era
tutta una scusa per continuare a
mangiare scivolavamo sul gelato al
cioccolato il suo congelamento Qui dice
Eh siamo nel freezer ehm ehm
Formiamo in ghiaccio no ma perché mi fa
volare la testa ogni volta che lui
sfracello ma perché sono riuscito a
passare facilmente questa volta Eh
adesso tu che sei rimasta bloccata lì
perché non capisco Aspetta ma tu sei
passato sul ghiacciolo o no ehm oh devo
evitare il ghiaccio No devi arrivare al
massimo qui e poi saltare ok ci riprovo
Ma vedi che non mi fa manco arrivare lì
ok mi ha aiutato Vitale gelataio
nonostante prima si possa srocerato 15
volte lui no Ma cosa dici ok Ah questo è
più facile dai sono solo dei ghiaccioli
Almeno qua non scivoliamo forza e il
vostro ghiacciolo preferito Perché è
diverso il gelato preferito il gusto del
gelato preferito è diverso dal gusto del
ghiacciolo preferito il mio ciliegia
mi piace Ah ok pensavo fosse amarena
amarena Sì effettivamente però Infatti
io mi lavo
la stessa cosa Dai allora A me piace
fragola ma anche il limone buono anche
il limone Sì sì e il vostro preferito
scrivetelo nei commenti
vediamo che gusti vinceranno tra gelato
e ghiacciolo adesso il gelato si è
sciolto Questo significa che poi
toccarlo ma fai attenzione ai coni Ah
quindi questa volta dobbiamo
piano piano
Ma no no no niente niente Secondo me è
fatta male queste schifezze un po'
bagnata Allora piano piano piano piano
piano piano ok E adesso voi siete
testimoni Avete visto che non l'ho
toccato la maglietta
Allora proviamo saltando partiamo
partiamo
Non capisco perché ci fa bloccare lì
15.000 ore dopo allora ci sono delle
parti di queste Escape Room che sono
facilissime mi piace altre
difficilissime Okay dove siamo qui
adesso eh La scacchiera di gelato ma non
siamo già passati qua Mmm Credo di sì ma
forse si ripete all'inizio lo siamo
passati qua Facciamo proprio niente ci
sono più gusti qua Ah Ah
volevo assaggiarli tutti e sono
scivolato dai
Dai l'ultima partita Andiamo No non è
quella la porta Cosa c'è qui le
decorazioni
le decorazioni da mettere sopra al
gelato tipo gli sprinkles non so come si
chiamano in italiano
ma perché devono sempre far volare la
mia testa senza capelli nell'aria ogni
volta che mi sfracello dai dai dai Ce
l'ho fatta io sta andando molto male
queste Escape Room Non capisco perché
siamo così schiappe oggi in genere siamo
più bravi
siamo delle scatole di gelato ci sono
qui credo che siamo vicini all'uscita
del gelateria Ma questi laser che cosa
ci fanno nel gelataio Questo è il
magazzino e il magazzino dei gelati tipo
Stiamo salendo sempre più su
Probabilmente questo magazzino è il mio
allora perché solo io potrei mettere dei
gelati dei laser a questo di gelati per
non farli rubare da nessuno Sì e ora al
labirinto piano piano Attento a non
scivolare
[Musica]
fa l'aria fredda che ti sposta ti butta
giù ma io sono riuscito a passare Ciao
proviamo a saltare in continuazione Ci
fa cadere giù
Yeah yeah
ah ah ah ah ti sei srotellata
sull'ultimo nemmeno Stavo solo provando
a saltare
Anita dopo c'è qualcosa che ti piacerà
quindi sbrigati Eh non mi direte bene Sì
ci siamo arrivati
Uffa perché devono sempre mettere i
ladri Ok allora
Salvino andare pianissimo Allora piano
quando scendono poi quando salgono puoi
passare Mh via
Chi prenderà questa volta per primo il
badge Ah ma c'è il vento che ti spinge
saltare Non mi dire che sei arrivata
alla fine a prendere il Belgio
infatti vedo gli altri giocatori dentro
però ancora non ho preso il badge
eccetera un po' di strada da fare
continua a sfracellarmi forse riuscirò a
prenderlo prima di evitare questa volta
Oh non mi dire che l'hai preso l'hai
preso giusto
cos'è
Oddio ho vinto Vito Vito l'ho preso
prima che è successo Anita Ti sei
sfracellata C'era tipo qualcosa di
strano dietro al badge e mi ha fatto
cadere però l'importante è che ci sono
riuscito
Grazie per aver giocato Sali sul ponte
per
controllare Ok ok prova a completare di
più la prima o la seconda e a me la
prima perché questa era più difficile a
me è piaciuto di più questa qui perché
era pieno di Giada la chiesa era più
difficile cioè tanto gelato adesso non
ho voglia tantissimo voglia di gelato
ora vi lasciamo qui cliccare per vedere
i nostri altri video cliccate su quello
che preferite Io vado a mangiare il
gelato Buona visione Ciao